no i don't
I should think one of the big handicaps
of the new media world giant bookmarks
are new media and the web series is that
all of the measurements of success are
emulating what television and what film
is that it spike mentality that is you
know a television show goes out and if
it's not successful in week one it's
probably over maybe two weeks because it
costs more money to make that show than
the ad revenue that's coming in so
they're losing money so rightfully so
they have spiked mentality they knew
that thing to be successful fast and
then and if it's not that's canceling
they don't have time for our audience to
pillow now what all the webseries people
in the new meeting people and a lot of
independent filmmakers pretty much
everybody who tells any kind of story
whatever story all have this I'm not
successful because only 200 people watch
I'm not successful because you know my
blog isn't cute I'm not successful none
of my stuff's gone viral how many people
have watched it is that how you met her
success because I know plenty of I know
for a fact Jon Favreau just didn't
interview and he said that
harrison ford thinks thought that and I
guess apparently thinks that blade
brother was not a successful man and he
couldn't believe that he thought that
and apparently somewhere along the line
somebody told him based on it not
hitting a certain number or whatever
that it wasn't successful so the gut and
he's wrong but he's the guy in the movie
so we're all being told at all levels
what success how fast you need to be
successful and we're not taking
advantage of this is the matrix we don't
need to spike because we are only
individuals or small groups of
individuals a publicly traded
multi-billion dollar corporation as a
millions of dollars behind marketing a
television show or a movie fails all the
time every weekend they fail we all talk
about the box office like it's some
measurement of success if the shitty
movie is the number one at the box
office it's still a shitty movie fed a
lot of people are going to see and and
Hollywood will make more because it made
money doesn't matter if it's good or bad
so when you make a story online put you
what I first thought was like everybody
like why isn't firing a lot of people
watching my show like it's a TV show
like there was billboards and like what
is that was a whole world just gonna
suddenly share your show because
everybody's making web series now it's
like it's just like CB radio it's it's
just another phrase it's a little you
know and instead of recognizing okay who
are you telling stories to individuals
how do you talk to individuals like you
would talk a any
like about your day the weather
service's watching your shows it's not
you know audiences don't talk in
demographics I think the way the way
that I measure success now is the number
of people who have told me that the
story that we made affected their life
gave them a lap when they needed it when
they're going through a bad time the
people who continue to find the story
now we're at this point 15 months out of
when we put out the last episode no one
cares
and the thing where you can prove how
the major corporations don't see the
matrix because the spike mental his
family guy family guy was canceling
because I was low ratings three years of
DVD sales box is like wow a lot of
people buy a DV we should bring this
back so they did the rest of development
cancelled seven years ago again by cops
with Emmy Awards awards they want cancel
no audience is watching Emmy nuts dreamy
seven years gone Netflix washes people
online watching that show on there and
so that audience built and so they're
sitting back on we should bring us back
and they did because no corporation can
see if they can't take the loss they
can't keep going to their investors and
going to the books looking at every
quarter and just watching the money that
they're losing over and over waiting for
a show that they know is good just needs
time to build no one's gonna give that
because it's not fast enough that spike
mentality so the people that continue to
find vampire mob and like what I do
oppose those people the name it will
like the next thing and the other
stories are they tell and then I can
come back and tell more vampire mom and
tell other stories and cute and the
audience is not going to fire me
companies fired audiences don't fire
please stop honestly the new
it really depends if you're trying to
impress sponsors if you're trying to
impress a corporation a TV producer
blabbity blah all those people they
think the spike mentality they think in
numbers are they here's the other thing
that they don't no one seems to realize
before the end of story teller there is
no way for netflix any TV network or any
cable network to tell a story worldwide
it's impossible because you have the
license it country by country there's
different systems the BBC there's TV in
Norway Volvo's it's all block by block
by block you put it up on youtube its
worldwide for anybody who has internet
access its worldwide anyone so feeling
our second biggest audience is in the
United Kingdom Los Angeles doesn't give
a about
the audience gives a about the
edges they don't live in Los Angeles
they live all over the world I didn't
intervene New Zealand of poets ago like
audience keeps finding and its worldwide
so I'm just one guy telling one tiny
little story for a long time and
just like a band that doesn't get
airplay it's like doing the road and
playing 50p 7,500 people and you just
keep going and we'll stay after the show
and you say hello to everybody and
that's Twitter that's Twitter that's the
book tour that's the speaking tour
that's the that's the when you go and
you do the QA after your screening
that's Twitter all the time and you
can't answer questions all the time at
some point you gotta go hey how are you
okay going on what's Easter like in
Switzerland okay whatever and it's also
that's really interesting I don't know
what Easter's like to Switzerland or or
anything else so I think that's part of
part of it is is knowing that if you can
be an independent storyteller and keep
going for years and that's the thing as
no one can see
you've got to look at it in years and if
you know the stamina if you need that
spike you need that ward you need that
validation and you can't take the slow
grinding monotony of audience building
and shake my hand shake then don't go
this route place bike mentality try to
get a lot of views try to get a company
that's going to give you money up
your story fire you own your story
continue telling it without you if that
sounds good go for it but I'm looking at
what I'm going to be doing 50 60 70 and
I know that the entertainment industry
has no use for those ages the audience
doesn't give up so I'm gonna tell
stories to an audience that won't fire
me for the rest of my life and they're
going to be small and they're gonna keep
growing you do but i'm not going to
spite it'll get hired by a company and
get fired and then be miserable I'd
rather be happy small keep going I'm in
control I final cut I don't have so many
telling me i want this actor in addition
your show or that act on your show when
i can't say i don't really like them
guess what i don't care i pay the
bills so you're going you're gonna do
exactly what I say because I paid the
bill oh right what we all waiting for in
and to do whatever we wanted to tell the
stories we want why did we why are we
it up by emulating spike
mentality box office and TV ratings and
Nielsen so Nielsen is your with your
heart if your gut it's your brain and
and you got to learn how to trust it and
it feels crazy and will for a long time
and maybe always it's uncomfortable to
chill out because you're not getting
validation that you can say to mom and
dad look I got an award here's me on a
on a step-and-repeat banner with
somebody asking me questions from
another web series it's on YouTube
that's what I mean it's like let's just
calm down and go to look we're all
little bands we're just playing little
little shows and little venues isn't it
great that we get to do this